were at the end of October so this is
the final spooky wonder in the early
1970s in a northern suburb of London of
vampire stalked the night London is home
to the world's most beautiful Victorian
cemeteries known as the Magnificent
Seven but by the mid 1900s these
incredible cemeteries have fallen into
absolute ruin and one in particular was
the site of one of them oddest examples
of mass hysteria the world has seen on
Friday the 13th in 1970 this cemetery
was overrun as teenagers carrying wooden
stakes and crucifixes climbed into the
cemetery ready to stake a vampire I am
talking about high gate Cemetery and the
great vampire panic
folklorist refer to something called
legend tripping it's basically when
teenagers tell each other a story about
a scary or a haunted place and then in
telling the story create the framework
for a dare that house is haunted I bet
you you wouldn't go inside legend
tripping can be kind of self reinforcing
so you know one group of teenagers goes
to a cemetery and you draws a giant
pentagram the next group of teenagers
who comes is gonna be like oh by God but
there's another ingredient that can make
this even more extreme and that's when
the press gets involved it becomes a
kind of megaphone on local adolescent
legend tripping there was a final third
ingredient that would make this a
special and amazing case and that was
the dueling magicians David ferret
stepped to the stage to say that he
thought there might be some kind of evil
presence a specter a modern-day van
Helsing as the press would frame him a
local newspaper published this story
does a one Peyer haunt Highgate Cemetery
and into the frame stepped another
magician
Sean Manchester he was to play David
Ference Foyle and he said yes not only
does a one Peyer haunt high Gate
Cemetery but it's the vampire of a
bohemian prince who is brought here by
Satanists to be brought back to life
this created an incredible press story
it just built and built and more kids
were showing up weird things were
starting to actually happen bodies were
getting dug up mausoleums were being
broken into but on Friday the 13th in
1970 it reached a crescendo because a
local TV station decided to interview
both David Ferrand and Sean Manchester
about the Highgate vampire and by that
evening the Highgate Cemetery was over
run by a mob of vampire hunting
teenagers this would continue for years
things got pretty out of hand corpses
were being dug up and stinked through
the heart a headless body was found
sitting in a nearby car a teenager found
a corpse
burnt to a crisp lying on the ground all
of which only further proved that there
was satanic activities happening in this
cemetery it shows you that it doesn't
take that much to cause this kind of
hysteria all you need is some teenagers
legend tripping some newspapers willing
to publish those accounts as if they
were legitimate and two magicians to
step in and say I'm the one that's here
to kill this vampire subscribe here and
watch more videos here also if you
haven't been to our website you should
check it out here I think you'll like it